[Music]
yeah yeah because sparrows were starting
2 000
okay good opponent let's go
e4 c5 and
we got to see how the smith mora holds
up at this level
let's go
oh yeah buckle your seatbelts ladies and
gentlemen
okay bishop c4 this is the line
i'll probably forget through knight f
whoa
knight f6
wait a second
isn't e5 here supposed to be good for
white
yeah
yeah e5 e5
e5 is definitely the move
this is the mock knight f6 is supposed
to be bad that i know because of e5
oh
d e
so we take the queen
i know that's the line and although it's
the end game it can be lost or black
here really really quickly
okay king d8 yeah so now i don't know
what to do knight i think it's knight g5
or i mean i'm positive it's knight g5
because
this pawn is hanging right but taking it
with the bishop seems like a very bad
use of our resources what does bishop
takes f7 accomplish other than just
taking the pawn and white black plays e6
so it's a much better idea to try to
take that pawn with the knight because
that's obviously a fork right
so i feel like knight five is a
no-brainer
no bishop takes f7 check was bad there
because the queen was defended by the
knight
yeah apparently i'm being told in the
chat that knight a5 is forced
yeah this is where my my theoretical
knowledge ends
okay knight d4 that is probably a
mistake then
so the idea of this move is
very clear i mean black is trying to
counter check on c2
okay so here's here's what we should do
now we should obviously well we should
obviously start by taking on f7 of the
knight right because that's not going to
hurt that's a check
king and now we should think so what are
the options well there are essentially
two options option one is to take the
knight on to take the rook on h8
then black gives us a check on c2 right
we move our king up let's say knight
takes a one and i'm not i'm not sold on
that position at all because it's it's
gonna be hard for us to trap the knight
on a1 the knight is gonna have an
evacuation route back through c2 so
instead i think we should just castle
because that takes the sting out of
knight c2 the black rook is still
hanging and if it moves aside to ga then
we can just come back and take the e5
pawn
and then we've restored material
equality but obviously we have an
overwhelming initiative i mean we have
we're castled our pieces are all
overwhelmingly placed
black's position is in shambles
but this is sort of a no-brainer
this is going to look good for the mora
okay so knight takes c5
let's snag another pawn some of you
might be tempted by a
knight d6 check
but that's a very very bad move because
black plays e takes d6
and the knight on f6 defends the rook so
black gets two pieces for a rook okay
we're winning on the spot here folks
we're literally winning in two moves
does anybody see how
i think we have two ways to win one is a
little bit more fancy but we're gonna go
for the simple one that just wins a
piece yeah bishop f7 and rook d1
you could even oh we could even start
with rook d1
oh that's sexy we could start with rook
d1 because
yeah let me just double check yeah we
could we could it's over
it's totally over because
if the knight moves this is literally
mate
and if the knight moves back to e6 you
might say oh we blundered yeah but now
we go at the other side we go bishop b5
check and black has to cover on d7 and
it's all over 14 moves
and that's probably all in mark's book
i'll have to check
okay that's it
but let's not uh take our foot off the
gut well we can take our phone at the
gas pedal
we can take our photo notice that i
didn't take with the rook by the way
because of a6
common blunder
and we might actually lose our piece
back okay so let's uh let's simplify
let's take on e6 now there's no reason
black is not resigning it doesn't even
matter what we do here bishop e3 bishop
f4
just get your pieces out
let's go rookie 1 rook d1
position our rooks perfectly and prevent
bishop g7 and black resigns there it is
okay
oh castling is a blunder oh
this is juicy okay let me let me get
mark's book
okay
so let's take a look at mark's book
now i'm trying to it's the one
one small minus of this book is like
you have to go into the index to find
anything
page 220 actually but you know that
holy smokes
yes you're right oh my god thank you
yeah so e5
um d5
sorry e5 d5 so
mark mark claims that uh the only way
for black to stay alive is knight q4
now let's get the obvious out of the way
if 95 then 95 d e and now bishop f7 wins
the queen
um that's obvious
so
the important thing is that this same
concept doesn't really work after de
because while you can play knight takes
c5 check black is under no obligation to
take and black just keeps the extra
piece here does that make sense
so according to mark knight g4 is the
best move
and then the line goes ed queen d6
although he says ed6 may be black's most
tenacious defense and now white castles
wow
queen d1 rook d1
bishop f5 knight b5 rook c8 h3
95 95 95 bishop d5 white has at the very
least a nominal advantage and possibly
more well clearly we have a huge
initiative
thank you curious gifting to joe
bruin hmm
okay
so this is mark's main line
let's see what he gives on d e yeah so
queen d898
king d8 knight g5 knight a5x clem i had
always thought king takes the lost
easily in 2007 a very young child named
ho
shattered me of this delusion
when he creatively found knight a5 over
the board
struggling to find a force to win i even
misplayed in drew white should continue
bishop b5 bishop e6 irish pawns takes
takes and white is slightly better
interesting white is obvious positional
advantage
with two bishops a clear lead in
development and structural pluses
which compensate for his two pawn minus
black's tripled pawns are only envied in
an art gallery
well
um
mark only gives
mark only gives
knight a5 he doesn't give knight t4
but apparently we blundered here so
after knight takes f7
king eight castles i completely miss
oh my god i completely missed this
resource
uh b5
yeah b5 is an incredible defensive
resource because it hits the bishop the
bishop has no squares
along that diagonal
it's not entirely clear what it should
do here
i mean this this this technique is is
actually quite common
yeah b5 um and the point is after after
knight b5 knight b5
okay everybody should understand what
the point is if you take then you give
up the knight
and if you take the rook then black
drops back to d6 covering the knight's
evac square and then g6 bishop g7 will
pick up the knight black will have two
pieces for a rook
so
this is a problem we should check with
the engine where i went wrong does that
make this does it not make sense for to
anybody why v5 is so strong because i
want it to make sense okay it seems like
it makes sense
rogue g8 is is a is a just black just
gave up i mean our our opponent just
totally gave up here which is
uncharacteristic even after 95 i mean
bishop e6
okay black is
in horrible shape but at least the game
continues like we would take and then go
bishop e3 or rookie one
you know one of those neutral moves but
the game continues so rocket shade isn't
serious we just go rogue d1 and the game
is already over
okay let's check the engine
to see where we went wrong because
castles is a mistake
okay so
apparently
yeah so let's fast forward to this
position it's plus four
yeah castles ooh black is yeah it's
actually b5 is
is equal um
okay so best would have been knight h8
might see two check yeah i miss
evaluated this position this is a hard
position to evaluate i i just didn't
know oh then we go knight b5 of course
that this is devastating i forgot about
this second fork yeah just knight b5 uh
how could i forget about that
there's just no defense i mean this is
coming
this is coming
yeah rook d1 i thought maybe knight c2
or bishop d7 yeah black can defend that
square and then go rook c8
so knight b5 knight c2
and now either knight c7 or even rogue
d1 first to set up the mate threat
huh
yeah
yeah i i stopped here rather than
continuing to calculate and working it
out i just assumed okay that both
knights are in bad shape so it's unclear
but knight b5 changes everything
and it makes everything look so obvious
so after okay rook chief is a blunder
yeah now
yeah bishop e6 would have actually kept
some chances alive but but after rook h8
it's all over rook d1
yeah and
yeah but but i think what this game
shows is the
the the the indisputable importance of i
know it's a cliche knowing openings when
you're like 2000
is
just absolutely you know it's not
negotiably important because it it wins
you so many points to know like basics
basic stuff within the openings you play
all of the traps like if you play them
more you should know this line by heart
you should you should learn it and if
you can learn openings at a 23 or 2400
level
you know you you give yourself a huge
boost
so okay and that was another game
gives us some youtube content and i'll
see you guys
tomorrow
i hope you enjoyed the stream thanks for
hanging out i'll see you guys later and
goodbye for now
[Music]
you